[Musique]
près de deux ans se sont écoulés mais
les souvenirs de l'assaut du Capitole
sont encore frais dans la mémoire des
Américains
[Applaudissements]
après des mois de travail la commission
d'enquête accouche de volumineux rapport
de 845 pages sa principale conclusion la
cause centrale de l'attaque du 6 janvier
était un homme l'ancien président Donald
Trump que plusieurs ont suivi tout ce
qui s'est produit et qui a mené au 16
janvier qu'on parle de l'élection
jusqu'à la contestation des résultats en
allant jusqu'à l'attaque du Capitole il
a été central il a été un élément
central
sa déclaration est fondée d'une élection
volée le soir du scrutin de 2020 était
prémédité indique le rapport par la
suite la Commission des nombres 200
gestes de Donald Trump et de son
entourage pour tenter de mettre de la
pression et de renverser les résultats
dans des états clés il a aussi tenté de
convaincre son vice-président Mike pence
est validé les résultats
la Commission conclut que dans nos Trump
a mis le feu aux poudres le 6 janvier
c'est lui qui a attiré les manifestants
à Washington
il n'a rien fait pour les calmer quand
l'attaque a commencé
le rapport recommande au gouvernement de
légiférer pour empêcher dans notre Trump
ou tout autre personne qui a pris part à
une insurrection d'occuper des fonctions
publiques dans le futur notre pays ne
peut tolérer qu'un président défait se
transforme en tirant cherchant à
renverser nos institutions démocratiques
et semer la violence indique le chef de
la commission
ce sont seulement des recommandations
à réagi en répétant ces fausses
allégations de fraude électorale Trump a
gagné a-t-il écrit sur les médias
sociaux c'est maintenant département de
la justice américaine de décider s'il
dépose des accusations criminelles
contre l'ancien président pour aide à
une insurrection notamment comme le
recommande le comité la candidature de
Donald Trump aux élections de 2024 et de
plus en plus fra est-ce que ça va
changer c'est peut-être les républicains
plus modérés les centres et ses
indépendants qui vont se tanner d'avoir
toujours des scandales associés à Donald
Trump les tours se resserre autour de
l'ancien président qui fait face à de
multiples enquêtes fédérales lui qui est
aussi blindé pour une performance
décevante des républicains aux élections
de mi-mandat
[Applaudissements]
autrefois l'homme fort du parti
républicain dans notre Trump est
aujourd'hui de plus en plus vulnérables
ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada